the election is a choice not just
between two people
but between two visions of america and
two policy agendas so every sunday
between now and november the third we
will set out the choice
on a different aspect of what's at stake
we'll start with the issue that has
dominated
everything this year coronavirus
here's the choice based on the facts
as we all know the virus started in
china initially denied and covered up
before xi jinping
let the virus spread around the world
even as his regime shut down travel
within china
here as we know president trump
understood
how serious this was but there's a
massive point
missing from the media's hysterical
misinformation over the
woodward book yes the president's public
statements
were designed to avoid panic so were dr
fauci's
the cdc's even the biden campaigns
they warned as late as mid-february
about a fear
epidemic the democrats now say
trump wasted two months doing nothing
really
let's do a little fact check you know
the kind they love
over at cnn three questions but many
more
lies by president trump including when
he talked about hillary clinton giving
money to andrew mccabe's wife that is
not an accurate description
of what happened in that situation at
all and we could go on and on
that was jake tapper immediately after a
trump press conference last week
later in that same show joe biden said
this
about trump he waved a white flag
he walked away he didn't do a damn thing
think about it
think about what he did not do and it's
almost criminal he didn't do a damn
thing
really on january the 29th the president
set up the coronavirus task force
to lead a coordinated federal response
on january the 31st he banned travel
from china on february the 6th he issued
emergency rules on infection control
throughout the nation's healthcare
facilities on february the 24th
he went to congress for emergency
funding on february the 29th
he expanded travel restrictions days
later
he ripped up the rule book to sort out
the testing fiasco
created by the bungling cdc
if the president hadn't got the private
sector in at top speed with biden we'd
probably still be waiting
on his precious government bureaucracy
to get it done instead
we have by far the most test in the
world and even
on tests per population we're second
only to denmark
let's continue on march the 13th
president trump
declared a national emergency just 48
hours after a global pandemic was
declared the same day
he imposed new restrictions to protect
nursing homes on march the 16th
the president mobilized the whole
country against the virus
15 days to slow the spread that was
before
shot downs were announced in the uk in
france even new zealand
which our media holds up as having the
perfect response on march the 17th
the president lifted restrictions to on
telemedicine to help protect seniors on
march the 18th
he invoked the defense production act to
make sure we didn't run out of hospital
masks
we needed more ppe so he launched
project airbridge
to fly in shipments of supplies in days
instead of months
we needed more capacity so within days
hospitals were built
ships were sent in the end not even used
we needed ventilators
so the president again invoked the
defense production act to get them made
here in america not a single person who
needed a ventilator didn't get one
and now we're sending them to other
countries we needed effective treatments
so trump secured more than half a
million courses
of rem de severe whatever we needed
trump and his team
got and no that is not fox news state tv
propaganda
it's these guys the federal government
stepped up and was a great partner and
i'm the first one to say it
we needed help and they were there
conversation commitment
promise made promise kept
and again no they weren't just saying it
to suck up to trump so they'd get stuff
for their state either i'm not doing it
to kiss the ring i'm not doing it uh in
a way
you know that i had just been for
forthright with the president
he returns calls he reaches out
he's been proactive
thanks to the trump administration's
unprecedented mobilization
we face this virus better equipped with
better treatments than any other country
and you can see the effects of that in
the case fatality rate
here in america it was lower than in any
other major country
half as much as spain's a quarter of the
uk's lower than france lower than
denmark lower than germany
held up as the best in the world all
this and we haven't even mentioned
operation warp speed which could be the
biggest deal of all
in the past it took years to develop a
vaccine president trump made this a
priority from the start
he got the industry together he cut
through the bureaucracy he made sure the
financial incentives were right
if there's one moment when it really
made a difference
having a businessman in the white house
this was it
as a result we could have a vaccine in
weeks
these are the facts preposterously
described by joe biden as doing nothing
and here was jake tapper's fact check on
that blatant
biden lie he didn't do a damn thing
think about it think about what he did
not do
and it's almost criminal uh woodward
also reports that
former defense secretary james mattis
said that trump quote has no moral
compass
what's criminal is the way these
so-called journalists are part of the
biden campaign
they won't tell you the facts and that's
why we're doing it here
we laid out for you the trump
administration's actions
but the ultimate test is the impact the
media and the democrats want you to look
at the
number of cases but that's obviously
misleading it mostly measures testing
and as we've seen we test more than
anybody we're told relentlessly that
america's outbreak is the worst in the
world that trump
caused our summer spike interesting
did trump also cause the summer spikes
in spain
in france in the uk and saintly germany
and new zealand
literally everywhere they've lifted
lockdowns and are we really the worst
in the world biden aids on tv like chuck
todd
and jake tapper say we have five percent
of the world's population but 25 percent
of the deaths
that is dishonest misinformation
anti-trump
propaganda their calculation includes
countries like china and india and
africa
with vast populations where you can't
trust the data either because they
deliberately lie
or their health systems are inadequate a
fair and honest comparison
is deaths per population here's the
johns hopkins data
we're doing better than multiple major
countries including the uk
spain and italy but america is bigger
and more decentralized the virus
response here
has varied state by state add them in
and you get a very different picture
the worst corona response in the world
was new jersey run by democrats followed
closely by new york
run by a democrat cuomo who has the gall
to be publishing a book next month as he
takes a victory lap
on the graves of the thousands of
elderly new yorkers he condemned to
death
by sending covet patients into their
nursing homes
and oh look it's republican-led states
that the media loves to criticize which
have much lower rates
but if there's one measure that gives
the truest picture of america's overall
performance
it is the proportion of excess deaths
over normal years
and on that measure the real measure how
many people died
compared to a normal year we're not the
worst in the world we're not even close
to being the worst
we have in fact done better than nearly
every major country
but an election is a choice how would
biden handle something like this
when he faced a pandemic of a highly
infectious disease h1n1
he kept the borders wide open no
surprise that he opposed president
trump's china travel ban in january
biden is so frightened of being called a
racist by the democrats woke
activists he couldn't protect us against
foreign threats
he couldn't get the vaccines either last
time he promised a hundred million doses
but delivered just a tenth of that
fortunately h1n1 was much less deadly
than coronavirus but biden
completely lost control of it as his top
aide ron klein admits
we did every possible thing wrong and
it's you know 60 million americans got
h1n1 uh in that period of time
and it's just purely a fortuity that
this isn't one of the great mass
casualty events in american history
had nothing to do with us doing anything
right just had to do with luck
if h1n1 had been as deadly as
coronavirus the biden death toll
would have been close to two million not
two hundred thousand
two million and this year one month
after president trump set up the
coronavirus task force banned china
travel all the rest of it
one month later on the night of his
decisive south carolina victory
out of 1418
words in his victory speech where he
talked about guns and obamacare and a
bunch of other issues
out of 1418 words
guess how many biden spent on the
pandemic zero
he didn't even mention it
so on the facts on their records trump
beats biden
but the election is a choice about
future plans let's compare
biden has announced a plan to make sure
no one would pay for getting coronavirus
treatment invoke the defense
production act to manufacture essential
equipment and put a command officer
in charge of the vaccine distribution
plan every single one of those
trump has done or is doing but there are
differences
instead of speeding up vaccine
development by ripping up bureaucracy
biden
is all about increasing it in his
platform with bernie
19 separate proposals to increase
government regulation and bureaucratic
control of pharmaceuticals
biden wants universal nationwide mask
wearing including
outdoors that's not justified by the
science it is entirely political
they say trump killed people because he
didn't show a lead on masks
but many countries have less mask
wearing than we do
even though it was encouraged is that
trump's fault too
some of the countries where mask wearing
was least common have some of the best
results like australia
biden also wants uniform nationwide
standards
we need real plans real guidelines with
uniform
nationwide standards
that is insane there's something called
the constitution
we believe in federalism different
states have wildly different
circumstances
biden wants to impose the worst rules
everywhere
carmela's california chaos coast to
coast
and finally of course this
so if the scientists say shut it down i
would shut it down
of course he would he's a democrat he
wants to control everything
these capricious pseudo-scientific shot
down rules they're not about controlling
the virus
they're about controlling you it was
supposed to be about flattening the
curve
biden would flatten the economy and
flatten society too
keeping the schools closed because the
democrats are owned by the teacher
unions
the pain and heartbreak of small
businesses closed health problems
untreated opioids
domestic violence child abuse 10 times
the life years
lost to the shutdowns than the virus
itself according to the data
that's what you'd get from biden more
misery more pain and a lot more
government
as they eagerly swoop in to take the
place of the economy and society they
crush
that is the choice on coronavirus with
trump
supporting the states and opening the
economy
under biden second guessing the states
and shut it down
open the schools or keep them shut
private sector energy or government
bureaucracy
a second trump boom or another recession
with the biden shutdown